hey everyone I'm Lucy and today I'm
joined by RAF : Tonio i president and
creative director at wolf eye studios
here to talk a little bit about weird
West Raffi thank you so much for joining
me thank you for inviting and I think
let's start off everyone kind of knows
you from working at arcane and why you
worked on dishonored and prey the
dishonored series is very very close to
my heart so I am genuinely very buzzing
to speak to you can you talk a little
bit about what it felt like leaving
arcane to set up a brand-new studio and
now being here and kind of showing your
brand-new game after the world ah well I
mean living our cane was very difficult
because it was it was my baby we had we
had a great team or a shoot friend with
with Harvey Smith and it was more of a
personal thing after 18 years of
anything you know whether it's marriage
whether it's you know it's just a very
long chunk of life and I think I saw
arcane as being uh it's it's own thing
at this point you know it was 18 years
old it's like a kid it goes up goes out
of home and that's it you know and I
felt it was time for me to to seek
something different and frankly back
then when I left and there was so many
reasons none of them really related to
any of you know I love if there's a
great great relationship with them I'm
so glad we did we dishonored and pray
and you know I'm very happy with our
King it's it's more like I felt at this
point that maybe I just didn't even want
to work for Tripoli games anymore good
morning Morgan
today is Monday March 15 20 30 to
good morning Morgan today is March 15 I
needed a break and needed to focus on
other project that I had some music
stuff I wanted to spend some time with
with them my son is also 18 actually and
it's gonna go to France so I need to
spend some time with him so there's a
lot of personal things you know I just
felt like I need some sort of a reboot
like I need to redefine myself so yeah
that's that's pretty much how I left and
back then frankly I did not even know
what I would do I would deliberately
want it like to kind of like go almost
like an on a meditation moment where I
would let the myself feel a little bit
before I would make a decision of what I
would do next I knew I didn't want to do
a more triple a it's just I've had this
experience it was fantastic I enjoyed it
but then once you I had it on out of my
system
there was a little bit of the same kind
of thing that bothered me over the years
the more the industry was making
progress towards more technology more
bigger budget bigger teams more money I
found it to be a little pressuring as
far as my desire for exploring creative
endeavors and taking risks etc so anyway
as I was taking a break for a while my
friend also former Arkane Studios by the
way Julianne jr. would be who who was
our executive producer on since
practically the the beginning of of
arcane actually he he had this desire to
create something to create a company and
so I consulted for him for a while and
as well I was consulting for other
people other other people in the game
industry and eventually I I joined that
that that company and
and and you know and came the president
and creative director so we're in the
process did the inspiration for weird
West come from so first you have to go
back to what is it that Julia and I have
always liked right and even from the
very very beginning when we started to
make games we were both of us for huge
fans of two games Ultima 7 and Ultima
Underworld and people know better System
Shock I think that nutriment world and
as far as Ultima 7 people would maybe
refer to things like fallout you know or
these kind of games the thing about the
first-person games like so a System
Shock and eventually you know Dave sex
for Harvey when you joined arcane and
for before for me it was the Dark
Messiah Ark fatalis and then we made
dishonored those games they require more
and more fidelity and higher hype in
production etc but the other side the
the ultimate style on the fallout style
etc which is more like its mark a remote
view tab down ish and saying doesn't
require so much so much fidelity yet the
depth and the type of interactions are
actually fairly similar to an immersive
sim so I had explored and Julia as well
the the first-person immersive same as
as much as we could and we had never
explored the the more like I so
immersive same felt to me what was
Altima back then really you know a lot
of interactions it was action driven
kind of thing so it was a mix of RPG and
action and a lot of possibilities a lot
of a lot of different ways to be able to
achieve them the the the boards and
explore world so we thought that would
be it would be a good thing to both move
away from the triple-a thing in an
elegant way and yet keeping a lot of the
values there is are so important to us
so why did the the themes come from so
you have this mix of the occult and the
Wild West and how he brought those two
together I think the thing about about
weird West so it's it's a general that
exists it's it's a very niche general
no you know it has been really put
forward in the game world and it
presents some really really compelling
aspects one of them is that it's
familiar because the Wild West everybody
knows it there's something really wrong
and there's no you know there's no law
so you can really do whatever you want
in the wild was the same way medieval as
this was a little bit the same and then
the weird West is really the equivalent
of the medieval fantasy to the Wild West
really it's you take a general that
people can even you know they understand
they have some cliches in their head and
we're gonna you know we're modifying
some of those that's and create making
it our own but then you add the fantasy
part of it and now you really have an
interesting world that is both people
can vote associate cliches and their
perception of what the the Wild West and
expectation would be plus the bizarre
night the the the monsters and the
mysteries your cult and all that and for
that side of things we like you know
Edgar Allan Poe or Lovecraft and horror
in general is something that is exciting
to us now this is not a horror game at
all right it's more like it's it's an
exploration action action exploration or
PG type of game in which there are there
are some bizarre and mysterious aspects
that the player is going to have a
chance to interact with and and they dig
deeper how present are those kind of
occult magical themes and influences
gonna be from the very beginning because
I think when you're coming into a game
that has a Western look you kind of know
as a play what to expect you'll be doing
some gun slinging he'll be you know
dueling with people what else is gonna
be able to do a game starts in a very
familiar Wild West type of setup
avenging someone or you know this kinda
this kind of thing which is very very
canon to the to the white West movies in
general and the people that you meet you
know Sheriff and you'll be used to that
word it's just that we're gonna little
by little insert some some weird and in
it and and hopefully you'll open that
door and understand more and more of the
what's behind the world
so what's like cool gameplay loop gonna
look like we say it's an action RPG
right the same way ever systems are
action RPGs what what defines an hour
missive sim converts to an action RPG as
a bootable Janna is probably the fact
that there's a few rules that are very
you know a cohesive world the world
exists without the player every door can
be opened it's not nothing is fake
there's a lot of simulation there's a
lot of sandbox aspect to it so that most
of the most of the players actions are
recognized by the game and it is not
like one way to do things and then there
are consequences to what you do this
kind of things is always something
that's super exciting to us and also the
fact that it's resolved by action as
opposed to being resolved by stats so
the game stays some sort of a very
visceral experience where you move
around with the character and like grab
objects and sort of them around it makes
a noise the character reacts to the
noise equals another character and all
these kind of things are so dear to to
values that we've always had and so that
doesn't change really it's just that the
perspective instead of being like from
the first person is more remote and we
playing with the camera as well and
we're trying to see how how much we can
push it down so that it's almost at this
point it's so is I wouldn't say it's a
third person but it's let's not top-down
as so much it's somewhere in between and
you have you can have several characters
so it's you know you're not you can
train one character but you have other
characters with you that can do stuff as
well and so colu does look very much
like somewhere between what you expect a
bit of a top-down ish RPG where you
explore a world in the travel map and
you go to locations and between the
locations you can you can have something
happening like some of you discover
something or you're being attacked by
something or some event in general and
you have some you have quests and side
quests and you know that's just that's
the structure and it's actually the same
time you make your choices so again a
little similar to what we've done in the
past were like more of an open-world
version of that and more of a remote
camera top of that so you mentioned
multiple characters I know you get to
play as more than one how does that work
um am i specking one character and then
seeing their story through to the end
and
kind of replaying the game how does how
does this work yes so we have something
that might might have been done before
I'm not sure frankly where instead so
for most RPGs that have played
personally it's you you play one main
quest
basically with one character from the
beginning to the end on this one again
I'm not saying really I don't know if
we're the first one not but on this one
you're gonna play a different set of
characters so you play like five
journeys oh and each of those characters
that you know they have at the beginning
they appear they have a reason to be in
this world and a quest and as they
finish it then something happens and
there's a story behind that you're
suddenly it's like a relay of heroes
then suddenly you play with another hero
and your previous hero is still in the
world is it still you know it back it
goes back to his farm or whatever
whatever was the story for for them and
you as the next hero can still find that
previous hero in the world and recruit
them so that now they can play in your
in your party as a follower and then you
keep going like this until the end
you've worked on these huge games like
dishonored and pray and like taking time
and approaching something fresh and now
you've been able to reveal it had that
reveal at the Game Awards and I think
you've got a Peter coming up soon like
you've been working games for so long
now how is the industry change and how
has your relationship to it changed well
I mean I'm 49 years old so I'm
definitely not the same person as I was
when you know we announced our very very
first game my first personal game you
know when I was around 29 yeah the world
has changed I have changed I describe it
as as playing new game+ you know what
you know it's like when you finish the
game and yeah and you already know a lot
and and then you have like some new
superpowers you know kind of thing and
that's how it feels it's it's exciting
it's still interesting but it's a very
different experience now I don't have
like so much of the it's not the same
type of excitement it's more this time
it's it's having something really much
smaller as a structure we're much
smaller and we still have we still feel
like people are excited about this game
you know they it was surprising and and
and and touching that people are so
excited about what we're doing next so
for us it's it's a new adventure
it's very different times it's hard to
compare it because sometimes people ask
me hey you know can you can you tell us
how you started RK and how can I start
now this new company I have no idea it's
like every the context is so different
it's oh it always changes so and the
industry is not set up the same way this
one constant is I have to you have to
work hard very very hard and strong
ethics and and and this energy to pull
things together and do what you say etc
like you very very accountable other
than that the rest is a lot of luck and
talent but you know the talent is a lot
of people have talent so it's like it's
part of it you know and staying on top
believing believing it's possible so yes
it is exciting it's after it's also
scary frankly after you know our King
became much bigger than I even realized
we started so tiny that it's it was like
one day at a time
over 18 years of being bigger and bigger
and bigger and so it's not even that one
day we win the lottery and go yeah
that's it we made it we just realized we
actually made it
and when you leave that and you don't
have the same power after that if we say
anything to the press it doesn't have
the same weight then then when I was
part of our Cannes so it is scary
obviously it's exciting it's just an
adventure all right it's been so lovely
speaking to you we'd west is just so
many of my things that I love combined
into one so when can we can our hands on
it so there's gonna be some sort of a
close beta or some sort of it says that
some of you some of the people can can
actually access to I still don't know
what are the detail around that devolver
is probably managing this and I trust
them entirely they've been really great
with us I would expect a few months from
now something that's probably something
to put your hands on again some of you
it's not it's not a public game or
anything like that
great well thank you so much and for
everything all the biggest new
announcements from this summer make sure
to stay tuned to games bot
[Music]
you